du ciel marie ou paul est une ville
rasée
la cité côtière a pris un visage funèbre
des immeubles calcinés des magasins
ravagé le résultat de trois semaines de
siège sur la ville ukrainienne
à ce jour nous estimons que 90% des
bâtiments sont détruits la ville est
constamment sous les bombes
un déluge de feu filmé ici depuis l'un
des rares immeubles encore debout
50 à 100 bond quotidienne selon la
mairie
et depuis quelques jours des échanges de
tirs en pleine rue ici de charges
ukrainien ce qui peuvent fuir se réfugie
à zaporizhya à 250 kilomètres au delà le
mot enfant en capital sur le pare-brise
pour se protéger en vain
quand on mal fui la ville on m'a dit ne
te retourne pas le long de la route
combien de morts des bras des pieds
arrachés il faut que les gens partent de
là tout de suite c'est fini pour marion
paul
en creuser des fosses dans le parc de la
ville et on mettait des cadavres par
centaines un camion poubelle remplie de
corps les déverser dans la fosse
cent mille habitants sont quant à eux
toujours bloqués dans la ville assiégée
pris dans le piège du conflit
ce n'est pas une guerre c'est un
génocide de corse les théâtres de guerre
ont des règles et les principes
de ce que nous voyons à marioupol il
n'aurait absolument aucune règle lors dé
la famille des enfants des vieillards à
jamais marquée par cette guerre